so Sean let's talk about what's been
happening on the ground in Ukraine over
the last 24 hours yeah the Russian
missile attacks you said have been
resumed covering the whole of uh that
Ukraine but not just missile attacks
also drones uh ukrainians claim they've
shot down three missiles and 25 drones
what's interesting though is that just
by you there's toner pill was targeted
twice
um we've never seen that targeted before
it's no coincidence that actually is the
home of the Ukrainian Eurovision uh
entry for the storm camps last night and
the first attack there happened just
before they went on stage call me a
cynic but that was not coincidence that
was quite deliberately targeted the
other thing that happened there were
four military aircraft that crashed
yesterday Russian military aircraft
briansk now that's 50 kilometers away
from the border it was uh two
helicopters and two military jets now
it's occasionally you lose military
aircraft through accidents but losing
four in one go that is not an accident
one now Russia hasn't made any comment
but what looks very likely is military
analysts believe what Ukraine has done
is deployed forward its air defense unit
to right close to the Border set a trap
for the Russian aircraft and have been
very successful at shooting the aircraft
down the other thing that's happened is
that Russia has found itself its
positions in Ukraine targeted in the
rear area quite a long way back quite a
long way from the front line good
example of that is up in luhans region
up here that actually has been about 60
miles away from the front line beyond
the range of high Mars and any missiles
like that and therefore it looks likely
this could have been the first use of
Storm Shadow missiles remember those
large missiles that the UK with huge
great range the honest answer is we
probably won't know and the Russian
haven't made any comments about it but
the one thing it shows is if if you're a
Russian soldier or you're a Russian bit
of equipment anywhere in the occupied
areas of Ukraine you're now within range
of Ukrainian attack
reports of Ukrainian advances in back
moves we've been discussing back moot
for a long time now what do we know
about that yeah the only really new news
is that Ukraine does seem to be pushing
back over a period of days now has taken
up to 16 square kilometers of ground if
you remember we were talking about
inching forward the Russian entity four
this is quite a big now the Russians
have claimed Russian authorities have
claimed this was just tactical
repositioning of their forces but even
you have any precaution the boss of the
Russian Magna military mercenary group
has said this was a route and it's worth
pointing out that the Russian army
traditionally they look at the flank so
they go around the top and around the
bottom trying to put pressure on the
resupply lines whereas the Wagner group
has been the ones doing the hard yards
through the middle and what looks likely
to have happened is Russia is
redeploying some of its army forces to
defensive positions across the rest of
the country that's left them a bit
vulnerable and Ukraine seems to have
capitalized
right and um so all of this uh
contributing to what looks like perhaps
finally the beginning of this
counter-offensive or spring offensive as
it was called um no big announcement of
course when they do that but is this the
beginnings of it again as you said there
won't be a Fanfare of trumpets and
they're a go across the start line but
the first phase of any counter-offensive
would generally be a softening up
operation that where ukrainians would
look to be targeting Russian rear areas
and we've seen a bit of that the oil
facilities down in the Crimea the east
of the curse Bridge some Rail Yards and
also the aircraft
um I think what's been most interesting
though is that um the Ukrainian
objective throughout all of this is to
have been to rid Russian Russia's off
Ukraine soil uh and the challenge is
though reality Crimea will be really
difficult to do and the Don bass will be
very difficult to liberate completely so
the land bridge is the most likely area
the real question is how far the
unicradians will get before they stop
now president zlinsky has always been
really clear I'm not prepared to
negotiate until I've got rid of
everybody but if you remember the recent
visit by zelenski to Chancellor Schultz
in Germany in the margins of that
meeting the language was definitely
softening and they were talking about
the door being open to negotiation in
the fullness of time now that won't
happen tomorrow because president's
lensky will still fanciest chances for
the rest this summer but it does show
that by the Year's End there is the
potential for both sides to be at least
in the right place to negotiate